degree now and power has been partially
restored in Odessa after a fire at a
substation left nearly half a million
people without electricity the
government says it will appeal to Turkey
to help restore power to those still
affected the facility was damaged by
repeated Russian missile strikes live to
Al Jazeera Zen Bas Ravi in key for Zane
what more are you hearing about the
situation in Odessa
well the government has been talking
about this very very severe problem
facing Odessa region they have said that
they've managed to restore uh Power to
critical infrastructure now what that
means is they are have restored
electricity to important city functions
like water the water supply drinking
water as well as drainage the sewage
system two very important things to
managing a major city and thirdly in the
dead of winter most importantly they've
restored power to the critical
infrastructure that supplies heat
throughout the city so when they say
that they have been able to restore
power to parts of the critical
infrastructure that is the thing that
they are talking about but what they say
will take weeks to repair is the rest of
the power grid what they're talking
about is so far of the half a million
people affected by this a third of them
have had power restored but very large
number remain without electricity
therefore without heat in the dead of
winter in their homes and repairing that
stuff repair carrying the parts of the
electrical grid that Supply electricity
to these people's homes that is what is
expected to to take weeks and speaking
about the repair work a senior official
with one of the major power plants
working on repairing this substation
describe the challenges that they've
been facing ever since last summer when
Russia began to strike the country's
power grid he described this substation
as something that had been a victim of
several Russian missile attacks in the
past the substation had been repaired
and put back into service but what
Ukrainian officials say one official
described it like trying to repair a car
after been in a car accident you can get
it back on the road but it'll never
quite work the same and that's the kind
of challenges that they're facing now
across the power grid even here in Kiev
residents that don't have a backup
energy Supply like a generator or heavy
duty batteries to power their homes
faced between four to six hours
sometimes eight or 12 hours of power
cuts a day and that is something you
really feel in the current winter
conditions and so that's the situation
in Kiev but in many places in the
country the power Cuts last much longer
in the city of bakmud currently Under
Siege by Russian forces they don't have
any electricity at all okay Zane thank
you very much for that update Zane Bas
Ravi live in key for us
meanwhile new European restrictions on
Russian oil are coming into effect on
Sunday this includes a ban on a seaborne
oil on seaborne oil products and a
global price cap of a hundred dollars a
barrel on premium Russian oil products
the measures are aimed at reducing
Russia's ability to fund its war in
Ukraine Osama bin Javid has one from
Moscow before the war Russia used to
sell petroleum products worth
approximately 12 billion dollars a month
in a year it continues to sell oil
products for about 14 billion dollars
European Union used to be the largest
export Market followed by China and
Korea that's now been overtaken by India
China and a gray area of unknown markets
Russia uses two main methods to
transported soil virus via a network of
pipelines to neighboring countries and
interestingly it continues to pay
Ukraine royalty for using the druzhub
pipeline secondly it uses in-network of
tankers which Ferry Russian oil to Ports
all over the world and they have now
come under sanctions from the European
Union the EU has set caps on Russian
Diesel and fuel oil and those ships
which are found not in compliance will
neither have insurance financing and
they won't even get servicing for the
vessels